not long after the new year began
another west african country announced
yet a new attempted coup
the government of burkina faso said last
week that it had averted a plot by armed
forces to take over the country i
remember that last year there were
military takeovers in mali as well as in
guinea the country of chat which is also
in the rest of sahel zone saw a
non-democratic transition of power
the omens had not been good in burkina
faso
back in november before the attempted
coup there protesters took to the
streets to vent their anger at the
government
and its inability to protect them from
jihadist violence
at the time the un said it was concerned
about volatility in the country and
warned the military against trying to
take over
now it seems the government dodged a
bullet quite literally
on january 13th ministers announced that
they had uncovered a plot by a group of
soldiers and civilians to destabilize
institutions
they said they had neutralized the
threat
for now at least
as of today 15 people have been detained
this includes from the military
two officers
seven non-commissioned officers and one
soldier
as well as five civilians
fears of course are currently high in
west and central
africa in the last 18 months there have
been four
including two in mali alone
there a military junta first seized
power in 2020 to end what they said was
corruption and weak leadership
initially military leaders promised to
hold elections
but they've since sacked a transitional
government
and suggested they could run the country
for the next five years
in neighboring guinea the democratically
elected president alfa conde was also
deposed by the military last year
he too was accused of
corruption also saw a coup of sorts
the son of president idris debbie sees
power after his father was killed on the
battlefield
joining me now is
founder of wati a think tank in west
africa hello sir thanks for your time so
what is it about west africa that's
triggering these recent schools
well i think it's always important to um
you know to remind that
the countries of the continent and even
within a region like west africa have
their own political trajectory and so
when you comment on the coup for example
in mali uh it is not the same thing as
commenting the circumstances of a coping
guinea so i think we have to be cautious
about taking these groups as something
that can be generalized as a trend in in
west africa there is certainly a trend
of democratic regression in the in the
region but i would not necessarily take
the case of mali for example as an
example of that because mali is facing a
security crisis and the coup was not a
surprise in the country like that
okay but but then still on that what is
giving rise to cruz in the region than
you think
i think the main issue is uh the way the
countries are governed i think that when
we talk about democracy uh everywhere in
the world uh we we have to recognize
that it is something that is built and
that is something that so which is
linked to uh with the capacity of a
political system to produce security to
produce economic and social benefit to
the people so when you do have a
democratic system with regular elections
but we you who don't have a sense that
the state is providing a security is
providing um jobs for the youths it's
providing economic and social
development for the people basically you
have a failure in uh you know the belief
in the democratic systems and i think
that used to give a pretext for the
military uh to enter in the political
scene and to say that we can bring
especially security back
we have best place to to bring uh what
the people need and i think that is a
that's a major issue
so regional bodies like ecoass and the
eu don't seem to be able to force cool
leaders to return to democratic ways why
is that eu and ecowas have developed a
lot of protocols on democracy and good
governance but they are more effective
in condemning military coups than in
enforcing bitter governance by you know
by the rulers as including civilian
rulers that we have in many uh part of
the continent uh which have been there
for uh decades and the au uh is not able
to actually force those leader also to
provide a different kind of political
practices in their own countries so you
cannot really expect those leaders
because at the end at ecowas and it's
the same thing at the au at the end it
is the head of states
who made the ultimate decisions and what
we are saying is a lack of credibility
of those organizations now uh people
don't believe in the capacity of equals
in west africa for example to
consolidate democracy because they can
see that those who make the decision
themselves are not good example of
democratic governance in their own
country
you know it is said prevention is better
than cure so how can regional bodies
then help prevent such crews from
happening in the first place
i think we have to have a more
i would say a more sophisticated view of
what is prevention of military coups
i think we have to recognize that what
the countries of region needs is not
only election it's not only actually
democracy it is also states that work
for the interest of the peoples and uh
so you cannot only condemn the coup and
uh you know try to prevent military to
sales power if you are not working on
changing the way the countries are
governed politically but also
economically if you don't consolidate
the economy if you don't uh you know
give
the sense that you are governing for the
people then we will have i'm afraid
always pretext for uh military rulers to
sales power and i think the bigger
prevention would be to work on the
structural failures of the governance
system in our countries
okay due to time we'll leave it here
jill zyavi founder of the west african
think tank wati thanks for your insights